sports are about gaining a competitive
advantage and for so long as the
traditional ways of gaining advantages
through through harder training and game
a basketball which I played it was
honing your jump shot it was working
harder in the weight room to become
faster jump a little higher I was lucky
to sort of grow up in sort of the Golden
Age of analytics as it pertains to the
basketball in the age really the
emergence of big data in sports the way
I look at it is it's just another way
like honing your jump shot or honing
your jump hook or we're getting faster
or stronger to gain a competitive
advantage on the basketball court this
time using numbers and data before I
really learned analytics I try to guard
a guy Kobe Bryant my estimation was the
toughest competitor that I'd ever played
against and all I had to rely on was ace
a the old eyeball test scouting report
Kobe's got a really good right hand you
have to keep him out of the painted area
he's a great finisher so yeah any Joe
Schmoe fan could could tell you those
things but after studying and going
through the school of analytics I knew
exactly to a tee
who Kobe Bryant was and I knew as a
defender trying to stop him Kobe's worst
case scenario and my best case scenario
was to make him shoot a pull-up jumper
going to his left hand all right
the average possession of the Los
Angeles Lakers in 2008 was generated
point nine eight points per possession
0.98 so he took the average possession
of the Lakers they were going to score
0.98 points every time they had a
possession and so Kobe Bryant only shot
the left-handed pull-up jumper at a 44%
clip so every time that he went left he
shot that pull-up jumper
he was generating 0.88 points per
possession well that's a tenth of a
point less than the average Laker
possession and so if I could make him do
that time and time again which is a lot
tougher to to do than to say I'm shaving
off a tenth of a point every single time
I'm actually making him detrimental to
his team and the way you have to look at
it is all these tenths of points all
right add up they add up here they add
up here at up there
I'm sudden those tenths of a points
become points and in NBA as we all know
the margin between wins and losses is
very very thin so those tenths of points
matter and that's all it really is it's
no different than them play in the stock
market you're trying to shave percentage
points off you're off your risk and if
you can accumulate enough guess what
you're going to do very well and so
guarding a guy like Kobe Bryant
understanding exactly who he is what his
weaknesses made me a much better
defender taught me to stick around the
NBA for for 13 years